[Aplausos]
[Música]
recentemente nos disseram que o papa
francisco apoiava dono de chã na corrida
presidencial à casa branca nos disseram
também que barack obama não era
americano também nos contaram que o
furacão poderoso chamado raven havia
levado acredita em tubarão às ruas de
rylstone e que aquilo estava causando o
pânico do texas
aqui no brasil recentemente nos disseram
que um banco havia perdido mais de 20
mil clientes em apenas 48 horas por ter
apoiado uma exposição polêmica no sul do
brasil
nos disseram que o lixo no rock in rio
deste ano havia sido totalmente
dissonante com discurso pronatureza pro
amazônia feita no palco do evento
nos disseram veja só que o juiz sérgio
moro havia chorado por condenar o
presidente lula é verdade
alguém duvida disso eu duvidei as seis
informações que eu disse para vocês
agora são todas falsas para o papa
francisco jamais declarou apoio público
ao republicano dono do shopping
eis aqui a certidão de nascimento de
barack obama
ele é de olo no havaí o tubarão aquele
que causava pânico em houston vem de uma
revista de turismo de ciência publicada
muito antes do hard chegar no sul dos
estados unidos no brasil meus amigos
cresce exponencialmente o número de
clientes daquele banco pelo menos é o
que o banco central diz em seus dados
oficiais
aquela foto do lixo do rock in rio foi
tirada vejam só em 2013
as quatro anos eu moro não chorou por
ter condenado o lula
aquela foto li é de março quatro meses
antes da sentença sobre o ex presidente
eu sou uma jornalista
eu sou uma fé tcheca uma checador de
dados
eu duvido de tudo de absolutamente todos
isso é muito bom mas afinal fé tcheca
que isso com a importância disso e eu
queria trazer para vocês
o caso desta senhora fabiana de jesus em
a fabiana de jesus estava na sua casa no
guarujá em são paulo quando uma página
de facebook publicou esse retrato falado
com uma legenda dizia que essa pessoa
aqui estava particulado pela região do
guarujá seqüestrando crianças para
praticar magia negra e que os vizinhos
da fabiana acharam que era ela
bateram na casa dela arrastaram ela
pelos cabelos pelas ruas do guarujá
socos e pontapés em 2014 meus amigos o
brasil teve uma morte
pragmatismo craniano ela morreu vítima
de notícia falsa
vocês podem falar assim mas isso aí
coisa de brasil só acontece no brasil
eu vou gostar essa história aqui pra
vocês é senhor aqui é um professor
canadense e mora no canadá profeta essa
religião sikh por isso ele usa turbante
bomba passado ele publicou essa foto nas
redes sociais dele tinha comprado talvez
o ipad novo estava orgulhoso daquilo
posou na frente do espelho muito bem no
dia 14 de julho quando a frança
comemorava o seu feriado nacional
houve um atentado iniciais devem se
lembrar um gato um caminhão atropelou e
matou mais de 80 pessoas e foto do
professor sofreu uma alteração zinha de
leve
ele ganhou um colete de bombas o ipad
virou um corão e ele imediatamente virou
como responsável por aquele atentado
terrorista
sem jamais ter pisado na frança
isso pode acontecer mas amigos com
qualquer um de nós
afinal de contas sou só eu que o público
self nas redes sociais
eu eo professor canadense checar meus
amigos é indispensável é
algo que faz parte e fará parte da nossa
vida daqui para frente
e acreditem pode ser fácil não precisa
ser uma fé que basta ser o cidadão
recentemente recebi essa foto como
jornalista me chocou
duas crianças abraçadinhos nenhuma foto
enfim forte e pesada ea legenda da foto
de informação de que ela havia sido
feita no nepal por conta de um terremoto
que havia destruído aquela região
o que o check in check faz dúvida amigos
em cinco minutos cinco minutos
eu descobri que essa foto não tem
absolutamente nada a ver com o nepal que
ela estava publicada na internet desde
pelo menos maio de 2012 que ela foi
feita no vietnã e no nepal e que não
tinha absolutamente nenhum
nenhuma relação com o terremoto as duas
crianças ela estava na verdade começo da
câmera porque elas nunca tinham visto um
fotógrafo
só que essa foto assim como chegou no
meu desapego e no meu é nas redes
sociais chegou de muitas pessoas
isso virou uma verdade essas crianças
hoje em dia são conhecidas como as
crianças do de pau pode terremoto
queria fazer um teste com vocês agora
levante a mão e filha com a mão de perto
quem recebeu um áudio minutos depois da
queda do avião da chape dizendo por que
o avião da chapa tinha caído por favor
fica aí agora pessoas que receberam
mensagens dizendo que o whatsapp
passaria a cobrar
olha e quem acreditou naquela oferta da
kopenhagen que está gordinho é gente
na mesma hora compartilhei obrigada pelo
teste gente isso são notícias falsas
mas a mentira sempre existiu e
continuará existindo
a mentira amigos elegeu presidentes a
mentira início guerras a mentira sempre
esteve aqui de novo
está tão preocupado com a mentira hoje
em dia porque a gente tem o mark
zuckerberg ea gente tem as malditas
bolhas aqueles espaços nas redes sociais
em que nós jogamos apenas com aqueles em
que nós aqui as pessoas que nós nos
damos bem já antes
são aquelas pessoas que compartilha as
nossas opiniões dos nossos gostos
nós não colocamos à prova aquilo que em
que acreditamos
isso é muito arriscado sabe por quê
porque a isso se soma a gente muito
dinheiro muito muito dinheiro
vélez é uma cidade na macedônia imagino
que pouco de vocês têm ouvido falar
disso
poços de caldas acho que a maioria já
ouviu falar que elas têm em comum
viraram pólos mundiais de fabricação de
notícias falsas nas duas cidades
existem grupos de jovens desempregados e
com farto conhecimento tecnológico
capazes de construir páginas e procriar
notícias com títulos para lá e
escabrosos e faturar alto com os banhos
que conseguem aplicar nessas páginas em
poços de caldas por exemplo há um
levantamento de que esses grupos
chegaram a mover 150 mil reais em apenas
um mês
vale a pena minha gente economicamente
fazendo desse falso e aí a gente tem
eleições do ano que vem ea gente vai ter
a eleição de sempre como mentira com
exagero e contradição ea gente vai ter
isso tudo ampliado à máxima potência
dentro do universo das redes sociais
a mentira sempre esteve ligada à
política lembrando assim alguma coisa lá
de fora
nos anos 70 alguns aqui talvez se
lembrem alguns talvez tenham estudado
isso
nixon negava que havia guerra do vietnã
acredita ele negava nos anos 80
hagan alegava que os estados unidos
apoiavam de alguma forma um movimento
nicaragüense dos contra teve que
reconhecer a mentira pouco depois e o
quinton acho que a maioria já se lembra
negou veementemente um caso com monica
levinsky sua estagiária quase teve um
ritmo por conta disso na europa não é
diferente
não é um problema da américa em 11 de
março de 2004 madrid parou quando as
bombas explodiram e mataram centenas de
pessoas
faltavam poucos dias para as eleições
presidenciais as eleições para
presidente de governo daquele país
o presidente então que josé maria aznar
optou politicamente por dizer que aquilo
havia sido uma atuação dos terroristas
bascos sabendo perfeitamente que havia
sido uma ação da al qaeda e as mulheres
as mulheres também declara cristina
kirchner na argentina repetiu diversas
vezes que bem a argentina tem a menor
dívida do mundo
mentira angela merkel na alemanha mente
michelle bachelet no chile mente não tem
nada a ver com o sexo a mentira não tem
a ver com o partido não tem a ver com o
país no brasil
lógico não vai ser diferente também não
tem a ver com ser democrático ou não
messi nos dizia que não havia tortura
durante a ditadura militar brasileira
figueiredo ocultou tudo o que pôde sobre
o atentado o ataque no riocentro
aí o collor itamar franco fhc de uma
temer lula acho que eu preciso dizer
sabe que eles mentem é a mentira é o meu
ponto aqui gente é que a mentira é
intrínseca à política a mentira sempre
estará na política em 1990 sem criou uma
grande mentira como para se defender ele
dizia que ele tinha em seu território as
armas de destruição em massa
temia que o irã em wadi se o território
iraquiano e para aparecer poderoso
inventou essa mentira que aconteceu
o buchicho filho usou essa mentira
contra ele e ele acabou morrendo de que
a notícia é falsa
bom meus amigos eu sou diretora da
agência lusa é a primeira agência de fec
no brasil é íntegro a internet não fez
check network é uma rede de checadores
que se dispõe a verificar o que os
poderosos falou a contrastar o que eles
dizem com bancos de dados oficiais e a
classificar se aquela informação é
verdadeira falsa exagerada e assim por
diante
diariamente eu estou em dúvida o meu
objetivo hoje aqui é botar dúvida na
cabeça de vocês eu queria começar com
algumas dicas bem breve sobre como
duvidar porque às vezes as pessoas podem
ter dúvidas sobre como duvidar
meus amigos uma frase dita por um
político sem fonte
não é para levar a sério assim é muito
fácil manipular as pessoas não acreditem
no político que diga diz que a causa b
por essa razão é essa relação causal
idiota ela não acontece em nenhuma
situação da nossa vida pense bem
terceiro cuidado com os números
absolutos os números relativos às vezes
alguma coisa assim cresceu 100% mas foi
de 1 para 2 e continua sendo totalmente
irrelevante
cuidado também com os dados em eterna
mutação que são por exemplo os dados de
segurança e saúde que infelizmente mudam
a cada instante
os políticos têm de memorizar algumas
informações e não se atualizar pessoal
riam mas viu muito alto de frases que
digam é a maior do mundo alguma coisa é
a pior do mundo qual é a chance daquela
pessoa tem efetivamente checado um mundo
todo antes de pronunciar aquela frase
conceitos amplos
estamos enfrentando a maior crise desde
1500 crise crise o que é o dólar é o
desemprego é a fome ea miséria exige um
dos seus políticos comparações justas
quer ver se não utilizarmos taxa por 100
mil habitantes são paulo vai ganhar
sempre para melhor e pior por ser
simplesmente o maior estado do brasil
sete dicas a menina que quer derrubar
mentira traz sete dicas para levar
mentira isso aí mas eu trago 7 verdade
também por favor deixe confiem duvidem
veja uma informação e questionem de
quando esta informação
recentemente formou se uma fila no rio
de janeiro por conta de uma feira de
trabalho que havia acontecido quatro
anos antes dúvida de quem escreve aquela
informação o autor daquele dado tem
algum interesse dúvida e também datas em
molho rápido na url www acreditem
existem www.bbc.co.uk x 1
e não é à bbc ok vamos lá você receba
uma informação bombante no seu ativo ap
a fatia sabe tudo sabe mais do que a
polícia federal sabe mais do que a pm do
rio
que tal você verificar as a sua tia está
bem informada de uma chance é muito
muito pouco provável que essa tia sabe
saiba sobre uma guerra greve da pm antes
do que todos os portais de notícia do
rio de janeiro do vídeo da sua tia na
dúvida meus amigos não compartilhem
façam isso de forma consciente e exijam
isso daqueles que estão lá
imagino que todos vocês têm aqueles
grupos lotes apenas exportáveis façam
isso digam a ele por favor não
compartilhe se você não tem certeza
porque informação falsa minha gente mata
eu queria hoje convidá los a levar
adiante esse 7 pontos por cento e pelo
simples motivo de que nós brasileiros
nos reunimos para torcer pelo futebol
para assistir show de rock ou
lambaeróbica você quiser pra rezar a
região que foi inclusive num lindo
sábado de sol para escutar o teste da
crista da gala porque a gente não se
junta para exigir a verdade daqueles que
vão comandar
nós precisamos meus amigos de um
verdadeiro é
gesto de checadores muito obrigado
[Aplausos]